we'd like to share that CBS this morning
won an Emmy last night we said at the
top of the broadcast I'm going to tell
you again why did Nora win the Emmy for
her report on sexual assault in the
United States Air Force Academy in the
six-month investigation she spoke with
more than a dozen current and former
cadets they told CBS News they reported
their sexual assaults to the Air Force
Academy
then experienced retaliation by their
peers and the commander's describe that
harassment my perpetrator would follow
me on runs he would send me horrible
text messages he would stalk me he had
asked me where I was going in my little
brown dress was he ever reprimanded in
any way he was talked to by his
commander about a very crude text
message I received and told that that
was unbecoming of an officer whatever
happened to that cadet he graduated and
what happened to you I left our report
led to significant changes in how the
Air Force Academy handles sexual assault
including a new safe to report policy it
says that victims cannot be punished for
misconduct violations like underage
drinking or sneaking off the base the
goal is to encourage more cadets to
report sexual assault I remember when
you did that story John you remember
absolutely it was chilling in the in the
studio listening to the things that she
said in the response from the officials
at the time well I don't have you
remember Emily was able to appear on
camera because she left the school but
we had to put three current cadets in
silhouette because they were afraid
about retaliation they were not
authorized to speak and when they were
and this is really important to point
out these were women who reported the
assaults they were followed but they
were required to do and then they were
marginalized they were harassed they
were retaliated against and I I've
written about this on my Facebook page
to get people that but I these are the
most courageous women I have ever met in
my life and when you sit against across
the table from someone who not only is
brilliant enough to get into a service
Academy but is a fabulous athlete to see
them sob like that you understand the
pain that assault and abuse can bring to
someone and it changed the way I thought
about a lot of things and to go through
that Nora not be believed that's the
thing that struck me when they knew that
they were telling this yeah Jennifer
Janosch is the investigative producer
who worked on this
and I think it's really important to
point out you this has brought changed
or that's at the Air Force Academy and
that's really one of the important
things that journalists can do is is
shine a light on something and hope that
there's change right they were brave
enough to tell their story and now
things have changed it's really great
Thank You lations